bonjour merci d'être venus si nombreux
m'accueillir à l'aéroport en plus ça
tombe bien j'ai pas mal de bagages vous
allez pouvoir m'aider mais bon
visiblement n'est pas à l'aéroport de
denver là on est bien à l'université de
savoie
c'est donc une toute autre aventure que
nous allons vivre ensemble êtes vous
prêts à embarquer c'est gecaj amené avec
moi quelques quelques petits petits
bagages un petit doudou
parce que évidemment quand on se déplace
il faut amener un peu la famille de
l'enfance de nos valeurs avec j'ai amené
aussi quelques quelques restes de mon
éducation et de mes études
le la bible de la gestion de production
notamment édition numéro un
mais bon avec tout ça j'ai encore pas
mal de choses dans ma valise
j'ai un beau stock d'expérience
professionnelle que j'ai pu valoriser
par 2 v m
lavea
v ah qu'est ce que c'est un vélo à
assistance électrique
un voyage avec escale non lavés c'est la
validation des acquis de l'expérience
c'est une procédure qui existe depuis
2002 en france et qui vous permet
d'acquérir tout ou partie d'un diplôme
c'est un processus que vous pouvez
enclenchée à l'université de savoie avec
une équipe qui est dédié et qui va vous
accompagner la la vae
c'est un processus qui est long et
difficile
moi aujourd'hui ici parmi vous c'est
comme si j'avais 20 ans 20 ans je vais
bientôt passer mon dut qlio enfin ça
s'appelait au gp à l'époque j'ai pas
vraiment envie de poursuivre mais si tu
tues pressé de m'installer pouvoir
m'acheter une voiture neuve et de
prendre un chat autant dire pas vraiment
vite poursuivre pour suivre à l'école du
coup j'ai commencé à travailler comme
technicienne en lancement après j'ai été
responsable de service et puis plus
récemment donc chef de projet en gestion
industrielle
j'ai connu pas mal donc d'emplois
différents et pas mal d'activités de
domaines comme l'informatique
industrielle le décolletage ou
l'ameublement et c'est au cours de ces
de ses processus et notamment en donnant
des cours à des élèves de licence
licence pro que je me suis dis bah voilà
pourquoi pas valider des acquis de
l'expérience
donc je vous disais en introduction que
c'est une procédure qui peut être longue
et difficile mais sincèrement ça vaut le
coup de le faire d'ailleurs moi j'en ai
fait deux comme quoi tout est possible
ce qui se passe quoi vous allait
enclencher une procédure de vae sais que
vous allez faire un cv détaillé qui fait
quatre pages vous allez y joindre une
lettre de motivation et vous allez
envoyer tout ça au département dans
lequel vous voulez acquérir le diplôme
une fois que vous avez eu la vie la vie
pédagogique favorable alors vous pouvez
enclenché cette cette procédure
pour moi ça ça a consisté à
à réunir pas mal de preuves de preuves
de tout ce que j'avais pu réaliser des
compétences que j'avais mobilisés dans
les différents emplois occupés
on peut mettre dans ce dans ce processus
toutes les toutes les expériences
qu'elles soient positives ou négatives
on sait très bien que même la pire des
expériences peut être valorisé
positivement
je vous prends un exemple moi j'étais
caissière pour financer mes études
et bien pour la vae j'ai dû ressortir un
petit rapport de stage que j'avais fait
à l'époque en 1990 donc un autre siècle
je suis allé au grenier chez mes parents
récupérer ce rapport de stage et donc il
a permis d'alimenter aussi ce travail de
mémoire et de recueil de données
donc vous pouvez mettre vos expériences
professionnelles vos expériences
bénévoles donc moi je pourrais mettre
apicultrice archéologue ou alors
bénévoles dans les associations à la
fête de la pomme d'argonay notamment
tout est bon tout est beau ce que je
vais vous dire c'est que toutes ces
expériences sont bonnes et qu'elles vont
vous permettre de défendre votre dossier
devant un jury de professionnels et de
professeurs
c'est eux qui vont valider finalement si
vous pouvez obtenir le diplôme en partie
ou totalement
et donc moi j'ai réussi à avoir une
licence pro et ensuite un master 1
aujourd'hui donc à l'université vous
êtes en plein processus d'apprentissage
on va vous donner des notions théoriques
qui vont être complétés par des stages
ou des exercices pratiques
mais je peux vous dire une chose c'est
que bien que vous soyez préparés que
vous soyez mis constamment en situation
de faire ce que vous allez vivre sera
pas du tout la même chose que ce que
vous aviez prévu
vous allez avoir des changements de
trajectoire
des surprises et de l' aventure comme
dit clément quand on sort de sa zone de
confort eh bien on progresse prenons un
exemple savoir nager alors savoir nagy
savoir nagy savoir nager
quand on est savoyarde comme moi ça
consiste à aller à la piscine faire
trois bulles dans le petit bain et puis
après on nous jette dans le grand bain
avec au loin la perche inaccessible
toujours est il que quand on est
savoyard on a acheté dans lac et pour
pour la plupart du temps enfin moi
personnellement dès que j'ai papier je
prends un pédalo c'est beaucoup plus
pratique
toujours est il que j'aurais pu rester
dans la piscine ou au bord du lac
tranquillement et bien comme clément je
suis sorti de ma zone de confort et j'ai
eu l'occasion
exceptionnellement d'aller à un comptage
de baleines à la réunion effectivement
rien de me préparer dès ma mise mise à
l'eau à tomber sur un beau mâle de 9
mètres qui autant dire c'est dit une
savoyarde
c'est la première fois que j'en vois une
faut que je me précipite sur elle en
plus c'est la peur où elle à papier donc
on va essayer de la sauver
c'est la vraie baleines que j'ai vu sauf
que c'est pas moi qui ai pris la photo
forcément j'étais en train de d'arracher
la main du moniteur qui était avec moi
dans l'eau tout ça pour vous dire que
vous avez le choix
vous avez toujours le choix de rester
dans un système scolaire universitaire
classique d'enchaîner les diplômes et
d'acquérir finalement votre expérience
par un cursus normal mais vous pouvez
aussi choisir comme moi alors
d'apprendre à vous servir d'un masque et
un tuba chose que je ne connaissais pas
avant d'aller voir la baleine
autant dire que c'est pas fait pour moi
la vie donc vous vous offrira de belles
de belles occasions également d'acquérir
des expériences
du coup la vae qu'est ce que ça a changé
pour moi
en définitif et bien à la maison déjà ça
m'a enlevé quelques corvées de deux
machines puisque je disais bon je suis
la plus diplômée bon maintenant c'est
trop tard ma fille est ingénieur ça
marche plus mais bon et puis plus
sérieusement ça m'a permis de
m'étalonner par rapport justement aux
nouveaux embauchés qui arrive dans
l'entreprise ça me permet d'avoir une
certaine légitimité par rapport à toutes
les missions que j'occupe dans mes
postes différents
ça donne aussi une certaine liberté
puisque je suis libre de rester dans mon
territoire ou d'aller ailleurs et de
passer la frontière
j'ai pas mal de visa j'ai tamponné pas
mal de destination avec cvae est donc
tout est ouvert
voilà tout ça pour vous dire que
effectivement la vae m'a permis de de
progresser et finalement de prendre du
recul et d'avoir une certaine liberté
vous verrez dans la vie il ne suffit pas
d'apprendre et après d'aller travailler
il faudra apprendre à apprendre tout au
long de votre processus votre carrière
et prenez conscience que tout cela sera
bon à prendre
aujourd'hui ici dans cet amphi vous êtes
donc en plein processus
vous êtes en attente de visa vous allez
bientôt finir vos études vous allez
travailler et je parle aussi pour ceux
qui sont victimes de surbooking
deux changements des escales ou alors
qu'ils sont carrément tromper à
l'embarquement
ne vous en faites pas vous de vous même
si vous refaites la queue prenez
conscience que ce que vous allez vivre
jour après jour fera de vous votre
richesse est votre valeur ajoutée et que
tout cela sera valorisables et
valorisant par d'autres diplômes
éventuellement si vous le souhaitez
voilà je vous souhaite une bonne journée
et un bon voyage
[Applaudissements]